[Music]
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 28 of you are
subscribed the channel is and always
will be free but if you enjoy the
content and want to help out please be
sure to like and subscribe
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing harry and
voldemort's final showdown in the
deathly hallows part 2
the day that lord voldemort's tyrannical
regime finally came to an end we're also
going to be discussing why every time
harry and voldemort meet and engage in
combat which happens a fair bit they
resort to using the same spells over and
over again with voldemort using avada
kadavra and harry using expelliarmus we
see this in their graveyard duel in the
goblet of fire a jet of green light
issued from voldemort's wand just as a
jet of red light blasted from harry's
they met in mid-air and suddenly harry's
wand was vibrating as though an electric
charge was surging through it
his hand seized up around it he couldn't
have released it if he'd wanted to and a
narrow beam of light connected the two
ones
neither red nor green but bright deep
gold
harry following the beam with his
astonished gaze sold at voldemort's long
white fingers too were gripping a wand
that was shaking and vibrating
and we also see this in their final
fated jewel at the battle of hogwarts
the bang was like a cannon blast and the
golden flames that erupted between them
at the dead center of the circle they'd
been treading marked the point where the
spells collided
harry saw voldemort's green jets meet
his own spell saw the elder wand fly
high
dark against the sunrise spinning across
the enchanted ceiling like the head of
nagini
spinning through the air toward the
master it would not kill
who had come to take full possession of
it at last
and harry with the unerring skill of the
seeker caught the wand in his free hand
as voldemort fell backward
arms splayed the slit pupils of his
scarlet eyes rolling upward tom riddle
hit the floor with a mundane finality
his body feeble and shrunken the white
hands empty the snake-like face vacant
and unknowing
voldemort was dead
killed by his own rebounding curse and
harry stood with two ones in his hand
staring down at his enemy's shell
my question is this why is it that harry
potter resorts to expelliarmus for
seemingly every circumstance
with the wizarding world at stake
wouldn't it make sense for harry to use
something like the killing curse why
would he rely so heavily on a glorified
disarming charm wouldn't harry want to
guarantee surety of voldemort's demise
yeah six billiamas ended up working for
harry largely actually exclusively due
to extraneous circumstances
but i can't help but wonder why harry
would opt for a common dueling spell
the first reason that i suspect harry
opted for expelliarmus is that he is
more experienced at casting it than
probably every other spell
this as opposed to avada kedavra which
we never actually see harry use seems
like a more obvious choice
furthermore we do have to remember that
avada kadavra is one of the unforgivable
curses
making it less than straightforward to
cast it's repeated time and time again
that in order to successfully produce an
unforgivable curse you need to mean it
you have to be able to cast the spell
and utter the incantation with
conviction
harry used the cruciatus curse another
unfavorable curse on a few separate
occasions with mixed results
the first being when he tried to cast
the spell on bellatrix following the
death of sirius
in this instance harry was extremely
unsuccessful
not being able to muster the necessary
emotions to produce a potent enough
torture curse
the second time was when harry used the
spell on amicus caro
this time producing a better result most
likely due to the fact that he was more
composed
regardless of these facts testing a new
uncharted spell in a high-stakes
situation like a jewel with the dark
lord seems unwise
expelliarmus was his specialty and he
knew that it was reliable it had worked
for him perfectly thus far so why would
he even begin to consider using another
spell
it worked for him in the graveyard so
why wouldn't he use it again at the
battle of hogwarts
harry's reliability surrounding the use
of expelliarmus is even acknowledged by
the book as his best chance
harry heard the high voice shriek as he
too yelled his best hope to the heavens
pointing draco's wand avada kadavra
expelliarmus
another reason that harry would have
likely avoided the spell is that he is
simply not a killer no matter what he
thinks of someone even if he is
disgusted with them harry clearly values
life
this is exemplified on a few occasions
throughout the books
first with peter pettigrew in the
prisoner of azkaban
no harry yelled he ran forward placing
himself in front of pettigrew facing the
ones you can't kill him he said
breathlessly you can't black and lupin
both look staggered we'll take him up to
the castle we'll hand him over to the
dementors he can go to azkaban but don't
kill him harry gasped pettigrew and he
flung his arms around harry's knees you
thank you it's more than i deserve thank
you get off me harry spat throwing
pettigrew's hands off him in disgust and
next following a showdown with death
eaters at tottenham court road what are
we going to do with them ron whispered
to harry through the dark
then even more quietly
kill them they'd kill us
they had a good go just now hermione
shuddered and took a step backward harry
shook his head we just need to wipe
their memories said harry it's better
like that it'll throw them off the scent
if we killed them it'd be obvious we
were here
peter pettigrew as well as the death
eaters he encountered at tottenham court
road were some of his worst enemies
serving the very man that threatened
everything he loved if he wasn't going
to kill them he wasn't going to kill
anybody
but on the notion of death i don't
believe that simply not wanting to kill
voldemort was the only thing holding him
back
i think there were a number of things at
play here things like mercy and not
wanting to stoop to the level of the man
that stood before him
honing in on the mercy component for
just a second i think it's important to
note that harry is not only merciful in
the sense that he tries to spare
voldemort's life but is also merciful
because he offered voldemort a chance at
redemption
in the books we're taught that an act of
great remorse has the capacity to repair
a damaged soul even one split using
horcruxes
and harry extends this offer to
voldemort towards his final moments
it was voldemort's last opportunity to
repair his broken soul
yeah it did send harry you're right but
before you try to kill me i'd advise you
to think about what you've done
think and try for some remorse riddle
what is this of all the things that
harry had said to him beyond any
revelation or taunt nothing had shocked
voldemort like this
harry saw his pupils contract to thin
slits
saw the skin around his eyes whiten
it's your one last chance said harry
it's all we've got left i've seen what
you'll be otherwise
be a man try try for some remorse
by using a disarming charm harry not
only verbally offers this chance to
voldemort but physically offers it
as if voldemort had decided to
capitalize on killing harry in this
moment then it would have backfired on
two fronts
one it would have killed him and two it
would have ensured that even in the
afterlife voldemort's soul remained
damaged for all of eternity
not killing voldemort would also ensure
that harry who held very different
values in voldemort wouldn't stoop to
his level
voldemort killed for fun he was ruthless
and saw no value in life other than his
own in a weird sort of way if harry had
tried to enact vicious revenge upon
voldemort ruthlessly killing him then he
too would have lost
to quote ovid the high-spirited man may
indeed die
but he will not stoop to meanness
fire though it may be quenched will not
become cool
we know that harry ends up becoming an
aura later in life a career that can
test a witch or wizard's character more
than anything
one such aura that harry looked up to
tremendously and the first aura he met
was famed dark wizard catcher alistair
moody who always tried his best to
minimize the amount of death that he
caused in his profession
given that moody regularly found himself
in high-stakes environments i think that
it truly speaks to his character that he
was able to maintain this stance
harry discusses and praises moody in the
books
i'll say this for moody though he never
killed if he could help it
always brought people in live where
possible he was tough but he never
descended to the level of the death
eaters
as harry respected moody to a large
degree then i think it's safe to say
that harry also followed this doctrine
of avoiding unnecessary death
one last reason that i suspect harry
avoided devadikadavra relates to his
history with the spell
this was the spell to put an end to the
potter family the spell that represented
the death and destruction of those that
he loved and the spell that rebounded
off of him 17 years prior
why would harry potter want to use the
very spell that turned his world upside
down
and that's it for this video did you
ever wonder why harry was so trigger
happy with expelliarmus why he avoided
the killing curse
to answer those questions and to give me
new video ideas be sure to leave a
comment down below
until next time remember
happiness can be found even in the
darkest of times if one only remembers
to turn on the light
you